thank you very much thank you Mike and
good morning everybody sorry we had the
mishap yesterday but we're here today
and we have a hopefully we'll have an
opportunity for some meaningful
conversation I know some of you actually
and I have had the opportunity to work
with Stephen in Rwanda and I visited
Liberia so I recognize a lot of your
names and i think i've met you when i
visited some of your country so it
really gives me a pleasure to be here
and also to be here to engage in a
conversation on a subject matter that
our whole community now has got
consensus there is a consensus that
unless we succeed in solving the issue
of Human Resources our progress will be
very limited in our field so I am
personally very excited that there is
that consensus and also we are seeing
people coming up with resource
commitment to put in this it continues
to be a very complex problems so we need
to and I also think that our window of
opportunity is probably very small I I
think the whole excitement about human
resources for how health systems
strengthening I think it's great but we
also know that people were funding
health tend to be a little impatient and
would like to see results generally
faster than problems these complex will
take so that's why I think we have to we
have to hurry and make these successes
and prove that if we make good
investment human resources we can in
fact improve quality of health services
and we can have impact and have more
access so i am delighted of the format
that
this workshop is taking its more about
sharing experiences learning from each
other and so hopefully we will have a
chance rather than this being just a an
hour and a half lecture that that will
be meaningful discussion what I'd like
to do is is present a framework for
solutions because we all know a lot
about the crisis of human resources this
thing has been studied for ten years the
joint learning initiative took ten years
to do a world study on these issues and
all of the information that we have all
the statistics we know that there are
four million preach the shortage of
Formula three workers around the world
we know that there's 57 countries in in
in severe crisis most of those being in
sub-saharan Africa and some of your
country is being part of part of those
but there's a lot that we know I think
what we know what we need to do from now
on is to move on with some solutions I
think we're also happy to report that
many countries now have some sort of a
plan or at least as there is an
agreement thanks to the work of the
global health workforce alliance and so
forth there is there is now tools that
are available and support from
multilateral corporations and so forth
so my presentation today will be based
on you know this premise that we know
for a fact that health workers save
lives we know that we it's it's it's
it's a reality we know that their strong
correlation between the density of
health workers and the probability of
survival and we have now enough data in
both infant survival child survival
maternal survival we know that in places
where we have a higher concentration of
health workers we do a better job so
so that's that's why we think it's it's
it's wise to invest in in health workers
and that's why a lot of the material
that I will be presented presenting
which is inspired by the work into
healthy is doing through the capacity
project and and others will highlight
investing in health workers and I'm
going to ask if one thing to do I know
that you've come up here you've made up
your you've drafted your problem
statement I know that Liberia is
interested in improving emergency
obstetric care right I know Rwanda is
looking at ways to increase the capacity
of health workers right I know that
Ghana is looking at ways to measure the
performance of district managers right
and what it is the last country i'm
missing you and ethiopia what are you
interested in yep let's see let me see
if I can remember I think you are
interested in not escaped me remind me
hmm that's it I was maternal mortality I
couldn't remember because it was so
linked to what I was mr. because anyway
so I'd like you to think about those and
one good way to do this maybe is to
think about you've been working on your
plans you've had a lot of budget now at
the end of this hour and a half you can
reflect back on how the human resources
dimension is going to impact your plan
or another way of looking at this is to
see of the four issues because basically
the model i'm going to present is going
to show we want to focus on four areas
in general and which of those four areas
do you think needs more attention in
your plan that way we can we
and you can use each other and you can
use us maybe as a consultant for
enhancing that that discussion ok many
of you have seen this too it's just a
map that uses are the number of doctors
of poor or population per thousand
population and when you look at this of
course you see that many of the
countries do not meet the 2.5 workers
for a thousand and inhabitants suggested
by wh 0 ok the other thing also that we
know is that our Human Resources
intervention is designed basically to do
a couple of things one is to improve
distribution because that is where we
have it's a question you can just look
at it as we invest in input and then
look at the kind of output we're going
to have but generally we're focusing on
improving distribution I know there's a
lot of talks about people are leaving
people are going to X place as the
migration that let's focus a little bit
on those people that are still there ok
we could do some intervention to improve
distribution so that they don't all
concentrate in urban settings what is
being done in that area the other thing
also that we could do is if we focus on
listening how do we improve their
productivity a little studies that we've
conducted in Zanzibar a year ago showed
us that productivity was only about
forty percent we were not quite sure
about what people were doing with sixty
percent of their times in general for a
variety of reasons okay so that's kind
of what the interventions are supposed
to do so that they can we can increase
equitable availability of skilled health
workers okay then we want to increase
the entrance and reduce the losses so
when you look at the overall picture
Human Resources intervention that's
really what we're trying to do right
okay and then we talked a lot about cash
shifting this is where tower shifting
comes we can spend a lot of time in the
political debate or are these good
policies are these policies for poor
countries I tend to go on let's be
realistic let's work with the workforce
that we have a problem is if we did a
hundred percent satisfactory job and
trying everybody we could train we could
we would still be reaching a very small
percentage of our populations just
because of the way our populations are
distributed when we have up to eighty
percent of our population still living
in remote areas we need to reach out
beyond the beyond the formal system we
need to reach out beyond physicians
nurses and midwives that's why countries
that have been embarked in an entire
shifting and it's not know we know that
countries like Bangladesh many countries
in ages have made many many progress in
Family Planning and other intervention
by using some version of Tosh shifting
right arm I hope we don't have to beYOU
know these you feel you've seen the
definition I like to show it just
because of the emphasis of rational
redistribution of task among health
workers I also like it because this is
according to skills rather than roles
and if we focus on those that would help
with the discussion that would take kind
of the political things and out of it it
it can be something very practical okay
so let's be opportunistic let's see how
we can now how we can take advantage of
this and that is really I like to
revisit it all the time because that is
the true meaning behind
task shifting policy by the way stop me
when you want or stop me if you have a
brilliant ideas that you want to want to
want to share how many countries have
actually embraced start shifting
interventions okay how many people are
still debating about the relevance of
tossed shifting or have problems with it
don't be shy okay anyway it depends on
what you want to do but you can't you
can spend a lot of time debating and
stuff my thing is we've got people dying
every day we've got people who need
services let's do what we can do to help
them are okay and and you know where
nobody is saying provide poor quality we
know our populations won the best
quality of services and that's what we
want to give them but it's it's a
question about being realistic right I'm
going to remind you of this too if you
haven't seen it it's in the wh 0
guidelines it's a nice kind of
description of task shifting I invite
you to read it again it has it has the
the four types of tasks shifting we know
that this was mostly inspired by the
hiv/aids work as we were putting more
people on a RV it became urgent to find
ways to to provide more services there
was a lot of Tears a lot of effort to
involve people living with hiv/aids and
other lay workers okay okay let me focus
a little bit more how many countries
have now human resources plants okay all
of the four countries represented here
okay great how many of you have costed
plan okay your plans are not costed yet
okay let's let's think about that a
little bit let's come back to that
because that's going to be very very
important I think it was it's a good
foundation building to have the plan but
unless we get those plans unless we get
to meet on it and get especially the
cost part they are likely not going to
move okay so this work is going to be my
presentation is going to be inspired by
the work that is being done with the
capacity project several of you know of
the capacity project and now the
follow-on capacity plus project it's a
USAID flagship global project dedicated
to human resources for health six years
ago we were very happy when us Eddie
decided to invest in this area because
that's not what they did in the past it
was mostly disease focus there was
always been a reluctance to invest in
these kind of complex a long-term thing
but they bit the bullet and did it they
took the work that Hopkins and UNC used
to do and put it all in one thing and
say and they were inspired by the joint
learning initiative report which she
talked about the severity of the
problems worldwide and so we are very
fortunate to be the winner of this grant
and capacity and we were just awarded
the follow-on project it is uniquely
focused on the health workforce need to
achieve the MDGs and it was launched in
two or nine and it's led by our
organization you have a chance to visit
the Washington office i'll be happy to
put you in contact with dr. Morris
Milberg who is our our director of this
capacity project and the project
currently works in none of your
countries we had some work in Rwanda in
capacity we did a little bit of work
with liberia in
we did a small small study in the first
first project we are present in Ethiopia
but we are not doing a lot of work with
capacity we did conduct an assessment
recently so we've actually have some
good data which we hope will lead to
accompanying the wonderful work Gabriel
that you already are doing we know with
the health extension workers and so
forth okay ok so the project also is it
is called human resources for health for
quality services it is not just designed
to be human resources for health in the
vacuum which is should be of interest to
you because unless I'm sure you are all
interested in how human resources for
health can enhance the work you're doing
in maternal health the work you're doing
in hiv/aids the work you're doing in
Charles level etc Exeter it needs to be
linked that's why we are proposing the
focus really on the health worker at the
center of every intervention ok so the
capacity project has adopted this
tagline kind of serving health workers
save lives ok so if we just start
looking at it from the lens of what can
we do to help the health workers and the
systems that support them ok so you know
this is just a few more statistics we
know forty-seven percent of deliveries
only 47 of deliveries are attended by
SPS that's his skilled birth attendant
and we know that there's one maternal
death for every 100 live birth
sub-saharan Africa and you compare it to
Southeast Asia where 72 73 percent of
deliveries are attended by skilled birth
attendant and you've got one maternal
debt for
every 300 live birth so these definitely
call for action okay we start looking at
our proposal for intervention we think
they're really four prongs let's spend
some time talking a little bit about
this and I will stop so for us to also
be exchanging a little bit about what
you're doing in these areas we think the
first area of intervention is really to
build powerful constituencies and we've
got a momentum to do it folks because
people are mobilized people are
convinced now and for the first time we
actually have an opportunity to do
something multi-sectoral right because
we know that we're not going to do this
alone in the health sector alone and
what are some of those reasons why why
is it important according to you to
involve considerin sees outside of the
health some ideas
i was born in a glitch yes the TV and
the nearest hospital was 80 miles away I
hear that's a fine for you to get to the
hospital you need a few need a road Oh
the hospital to be there you need
finance yes and so there are so many
things that I put into the club with
other components of these other
ministries that are important steps you
can take a pill don't eat one because
you will never get help a treasure is
multifactorial there sometimes even us
and delivery I have some of these areas
and to prove it yes give an example of a
extension officer for the lack of the
help liberated it comes to help
lubricated so there are so many facts
espetus and therefore you can't say
because Ministry of how is the one you
to grab another resource production
ended up sector others on Monday you can
find it comes between absolute
universities and not handle minute
nobody
absolutely absolutely any other ideas
but why we we want to to bring in all
these constituencies yes Steven can
everybody hear you want to use the
microphones given yeah you needed a
partitionless to go wrong with you
because most of the stuff that arias is
talking about whether education to get
the education ministry to walk hand in
hand with ministry of education whether
flash culture to build the roads you
have absolutely no and have the support
of the politician absolutely you will go
along better absolutely absolutely you
cannot just dismiss them you don't have
to eat then I cannot you have to use
their political agreement to advance
their case so if you alive with them and
get them to embrace health like they're
doing beautifully in their decentralized
system in Rwanda that I'll be very very
important Patrick is and a time data
that has been said and relating to what
we learned yesterday and the previous
day who these are the people that are
going to to facilitate the uptake of
interventions yes so if we can expand
the constituencies within which we can
operate them interventions and
strategies that are seen to accelerate
improvements in the health sector will
either be are scattered up like why they
hired yesterday so would be a much more
in able to achieve the goals in a
shorter China time then that is right
there's something very practical
that okay so so building powerful
consistencies extremely important and
that this is the example of Uganda where
they've really mobilized behind this or
to form these these coalition's and what
the purpose of really coming up with a
sound advocacy strategy right because
you just you build a constituency you
don't want to stop their real purpose is
to be able to come up with a good
advocacy strategy in your advocacy
strategy of course need to to target
very different constituencies so in
Uganda that's that's what they're doing
informed once they get some data and
they saw the severity of the problem and
then they so the extreme difficulties
related to distribution of health
workers especially in northern Uganda
where it's very very sparse there was
they really make a concerted effort to
come up with a good advocacy strategy
and they are working on that and they
have a group which made up of various
people representing various sectors that
are regularly meeting and regularly
checking our progress in human resources
for help okay yes
discipline their place is really driving
it and when the money doesn't come
sequences yep so making some form of not
finding I said that you can in doing
that you deliver we just want to hold
this because this is so important than
guys that's the stuff I'm interested in
I think unless and you are a better
place than anybody to come up with these
solutions it's yes how can we be
creative enough from where we're sitting
so that this is not just a project
that's going to come and go I mean if
all the intervention is only attached to
the capacity project providing new
resources for five years and then when
they go so from the onset what mechanism
needs to be in place so that we've got
true ownership so we know who is on the
driver's seat and that we know how we're
going to sustain this effort without
assistance for me when we start talking
about country ownership this is what
we're talking about and these are and I
don't think it will be right for just
the World Bank and USAID and of the
ature and people to be start started
waking one day like we're doing these
days to talk about country ownership I
think it's a very noble idea I think
that's what we should be doing but I
think you are the guys we're going to
make it happen even unless we find a way
for the discussion to be a meaningful
discussion any way I can get off on that
but
I'd like us to actually come back to
that because you know for me that's
going to be the richness of this
discussion if we agree that this is
something to be done I'm more interested
in what are you going to do in your
plans to make sure that you are working
toward our constituencies that is driven
by you yes okay it looks so much easier
when you're telling someone how to do
that right I'm trying to do it yourself
my question both with your experience or
delegates experience um I really like
what you I can't remember who said it
but what you just said about people have
to like the Minister of Finance or
Minister of Education has to come to the
table with resources or a commitment
with resources but if the economic
development just isn't there my question
is um what really are we telling
ministries of health I mean how can they
possibly make something work and sustain
post-project if the economic development
isn't there and I really wondered if
anyone had any bright ideas about how
you had engaged ministers of finance
particularly in the very beginning of a
large-scale you know capacity building
project what works cuz I don't think
it's just data because there's so much
data they could read the data and be
alarmed how everybody is but has anyone
used another tactic that has been
successful right question yes thank you
actually it's not to answer Betty's
question but it's just a comment I think
it all depends on the political setting
of you know the country for example if I
take in a day to PS case it's not a
matter of how should I say you know
bargaining with the Ministry of Finance
that you should give us you know this
amount of money for this program and so
on but it's a collective responsibility
enough for the government basically
meaning it's you know the political
commitment to pursue on certain
initiatives I think first
the whatever program or project we're
designing has to be you know a demand
based meaning that is a critical and you
know priority need for that country for
example and if there is this buy-in from
the start then obviously you know the
government will take in order
responsibility otherwise you know if
ministries try to share whatever
resource is available in oh this should
come for this program for that project
and so on you know it's very difficult
to achieve you know the eventual goal it
should be like you know a football team
I mean if we have to score whatever goal
I mean all the players have to really
play you know their role and and for
example if you know the Ministry of
Health insists on get getting certain
amount of money for this and that what
about the water resources which is
critical input for health and also the
education so unless we have in a proper
application again we cannot achieve in
on in the area often so it all lies on
you know the political leadership of you
know the country and I think this is I
mean the ETA on scenario by the way that
like our minister does not necessarily
fight you not to get the resources you
know for my program and whatever because
he I mean will also be responsible
equally you know whatever is achieved by
the Ministry of Water Resources by the
Ministry of Education and soul because
that's how we said you know the
constituencies you know all the players
have to really you know go together but
the most important thing whatever
initiative we have should be you know a
demand based like if we are just relying
on world herb and USAID I think if it's
a need or our critical I man or strategy
kino objective then obviously we have to
sustain it but if it was some something
initiative that was just you know driven
you know pushed from external obviously
you know it will not sustain that much
thank you absolutely yes
I'm just trying to follow the track of
the discussion what do you mean by
building powerful constituency's is it
convincing the powers that p or is the
communities who are the constraints is a
solid I'm concerned the consequences if
they are going to be very powerful
another bureaucrats at the top it's not
the Parliament or the ministers or but
the people what do the people who want
and then we if you are talking about
serving health workers saving lives if
you are going to use the health workers
at the constituency and the archons 20
the a demon's might be completely
different from what the community needs
they might be asking you the day in and
day out about salary increments or they
are intent to improve their level of
education from a diploma say to a degree
or from a degree to a postgraduate
degree might be related to salary
increments and not necessarily to
improving their skills and knowledge so
can we crack the discussion can we make
it more palatable eatable in that way i
just i am getting lost in the discussion
so okay what are we talking about which
constitutes are we talking about and can
you place yeah well let me let me
actually I'm glad you asked that
question because I think I think we have
to be careful about what level we're
talking about I think there are actually
three levels from my point of view I
think there's a global level the
regional level and the country level
okay I think it's the country level it's
up to you to decide and form i think i
think really to make progress globally i
think there needs to be a constituency
in coalition building so that we can
address this because the problem
actually the major problem i see
personally is that bilateral aid is ok
you can do a few things
this problem is really global right we
know that the West needs to do its part
to curb the demand we need that you know
there are some things you could do you
could do a better job by maybe tying the
different schools the schools in the
West with so there's been some twinning
experience you know wh or the World Bank
USAID differed Global Fund they all have
to come together so there are some
considerin see building that needs to
happen at that level okay regionally I
think we need to do a better job our
training institutions certainly we could
invest on our training institutions we
could we could we could work through
these political you know whether it's
the echo us whether it's a sadek whether
this regional grouping that already
exists what needs to be done we need to
build constituency's at that level and
you're right Lee you're right i mean
then then the work and i think that's
where you're mostly interested at the
country level you also need to do some
coalition building so this is not meant
actually to prescribe but it's just to
provide the framework for doing this and
you are absolutely right you've got two
segments these things you've got to
decide so that and that's part of
considers the building and advocacy
developing an advocacy strategy its
first of all people need to come
together they need to say ok if we sit
at this table to discuss this issue what
is the common purpose for all of us and
then focus on that ok does it help great
ok so the second part then is really
optimizing optimizing policies arm and
plants because once we've got these
advocacies and and and so forth that's
really what we want to do we want to get
to a place where are we address these
plants now what we are proposing is this
concept of health teams because I think
if you look at the task shifting
discussions and all of that I think we
are implicitly saying what you need to
do is invest in the
motion of health teams health teams that
this concept and we know that that's not
really the way we do business generally
it's very fragmented according to roles
according to doctors to nurses it was
but if we proposed the concept of teams
that might be helpful another area of
policy is in the area of human resources
management and human resources
information systems I know that the work
in Uganda that I described earlier was
all informed by human resources
information system and the data that was
generated from that so some policies
around these areas would be extremely
useful financing so this is one area
where definitely you need to sit at the
table I think what we hear all the time
is that the people from the ministries
of Health tend to be the least powerful
advocates they are the one that are
really not prepared or trained to be
good advocate for health because things
have come so easy as people usually say
okay well we know that the donors will
take care of this part of Health so we
don't have to worry about it those days
are gone okay I think we need to we need
to make our commitment we have yet to
meet the Abuja targets of fifteen
percent and so forth so a lot of work to
be done in this area but we do need to
optimize policies and plans and Kenya
has been doing a lot of work in this
area the example would like to to share
for example when Kenya decided to look
at their human resources information
system and
found out not only they will pull
distribution but Kenya happens to be a
country where you actually had a surplus
of health workers you had a lot of
midwives who were who left the health
system just because of variety of reason
low salaries poor working conditions and
so forth security and there's just a lot
of reason but a lot of concentration
then and one very courageous policy
which the Kenyan government tried for a
short period of time was this idea of
outsourcing recruitment of health
workers they got some they got some
funding some a lot of people were
skeptical whether the government was
actually going to absorb those but you
may have read about this emergency
hiring plan which so they finally agreed
okay we're going to give this a try
we're going to outsource actually the
recruitment of 800 additional nurses to
put back into the system and and and I
was done through the local Deloitte's
office and and some some support from
the old capacity project and it's about
four months time 800 people were
recruited oriented and deployed in in
very remote areas and so forth and at
the end of three years the government of
Kenya has to actually absorb those I
mean careful detail my attention was
paid to making sure that these people
would not pay salaries that were very
different and that the ministry jointly
did this I mean the it's so if you're
interested in that model I'll be happy
to talk to you later or share or direct
you to a site where you can learn but
that was so a good example where some
some good policies were enacted
courageous policies really
okay let me move on quick so that we can
come and have a little bit more
discussion the one that we we spend a
lot of time on is this developing the
health workforce and we know that this
this one we have a lot of challenges in
this one this is the one where we see in
service training pre-service training
continuing medical education continuing
professional education our pre-service
education I think what we are talking
about here really is what kind of reform
are we going to enact so that our
pre-service education system is more
efficient we know that most of our
countries are still using the model that
we inherited from the old colonial
powers we also know that in general it's
not a system designed to really serve
the larger communities that we try to
serve so I just think we need we need to
do something about rethinking about
pre-service education differently I
don't think it's simply about reforming
the curriculum or something it's really
thinking thinking about this your work
in health extension workers certainly
fits here as a very courageous approach
but in developed in developing the
health workforce this is an area that
that needs a lot of work we know what
the problem is with in-service training
right in-service training generally is
not done in a comprehensive strategic
way it is can to be ad hoc training it
is an area where there's very little
coordination and you have yet to have in
the country's a place which is seen as
the locals of in-service training I
think you're trying with the truck to
coordinate a lot of Europe in-service
training right to sort of centralized
and get you know get a national
curriculum for various things and so
forth but by far um it's it's an area
that has more problem in it and the
problem is its ketchup training because
we are training and retraining and it's
very inefficient and there are problems
also with who we select who goes to
training and all of the issues you know
about them and the fact that they tend
to be more motivations for people and so
forth and so forth but we need we need
to address that and Molly they had an
interesting yes yes Elias professional
associations yeah see we we tend to let
the public sector absorb such and and we
know that the money is just not there
you can pay well where you kind of talk
people and we tried having a service
education but the units we set up could
not take off well we depended on
partners to bring in money to on areas
they wanted but I look at the
professional associations really being
incorrect to use the CMEs as part of
that in service education and look at
perhaps the university's you've amount
of you you pass me out as a doctor you
should be mountain
the causes that people can look for
funding scholarship corporate
organizations can come in and sponsor
people but I agree that it should be
something that we have to work at and
make sure that it is structured so
whether for every person to be a current
of good standing with your professional
organizer professional body you must
have had two or three the Austrian smile
can be defined by the public sector but
we allow others to come in to help
absolutely up yes Sarah question there
agree with you that the pre-service
education really monotonous and
sometimes irrelevant because we teach
all sorts of mitochondria sand volga
bodies yeah you know much of which they
will not use in any in any way that gets
mind-boggling details of anatomy and
physiology so we have to think about the
content of the of what we teach related
to do the job and I think there is the
Rimmer's a gap I agree with you secondly
in the in-service training in some
places like in my country we do it quite
often but it degenerates into hunting
for per diems and essays you see so
alternative approach to be thin for
instance i would suggest that we have in
self learning atmospheres or me that we
make the hospital's the health centers
environment make it an environment where
people can learn from their experiences
for Sulu discussion
in mutual you know mutual one teaching
the other and if we assess theoretically
at we find the best ones and reward them
what them for excellence they might be
motivated I think these are most
prescribing anything but there should be
a new way of doing magical education
health workforce education the
traditional methods they without follow
them they are a must we have it's a
necessity but we can't rely on them a
hundred percent I i we have to modify
them that's what I want to say I I think
this is so important and I just look at
all so the opportunities that we have
today in terms of new technologies we we
we can do a better job I mean I think we
actually the opportunities today are so
much better and I totally agree I think
we need to any think I just think we
can't buy I think there's a lot of
values to periodically bringing people
in the capital for some training and so
forth but I don't think we can rely on
it as we have done in the past it is
just not an efficient system then it
becomes first of all people forget that
it's not just training for the sake of
training it's a it's supposed to be a
mother you know it's supposed to be for
something that's it but if we harness
the power of new technologies I actually
think this is such a promising area if
because and look at all the stuff now
you you are able to do I mean I know
there's still a lot of skeptics and I
think there's still a lot of issues with
infrastructure but it's moving much much
faster than we you know I look at the
difference in East Africa now ever since
the undersea cable was installed the
broadband has increased I mean there are
a few things you could do so and and
there are tools actually there they are
there solutions that are beginning that
are beginning to surface there are a lot
of stuff we could do in terms of
decision support for health workers
their ways now that 10 years ago we
could not think about that we can
improve their preparation their
readiness for certain things through
telephony through computers where they
are available through some some tools so
I think we have to put our heads plus we
are investing in the next generation of
healthcare workers to and these happen
to be generation that is growing up with
these tools that is growing up with
these social media opportunities and so
forth so I think there is there is great
great opportunities and I totally agree
with you this we need to just have a
paradigm shift we need to find ways to
better take the training to the workers
rather than having them move because you
know not only you're depriving the
service delivery sites from qualified
workers while these people are training
but then the cost is just not
sustainable somebody was trying to raise
their hand was that brother Oh was that
Juliette yeah thank you um one thing I
can I don't like what we've done in in
in Ronda in our hospital is to make it a
part of the the job description of
either the head nurses or the you know
the specialists and we've created an
environment where at least every
Thursday and actually can't even get
enough if you take if you call people
away on a Thursday afternoon they get
really upset because it's cme that first
day afternoon every Thursday afternoon
so it's been working very well if you
can actually create it into your job
description I think it can go far
because i'm telling you we can you can
if you call the meeting on a thursday
you get a lot of set people
because it's it's known it's everywhere
and what actually recently I think like
a couple weeks ago what the minister
decided is to actually tap into
different centers that have the e health
services to to tap into our cm es on
Thursdays so now it's a mandatory thing
for at least three hospitals in the
country to tune in to the CMEs and also
we have nursing education as well so
it's really good and you can't really
you know like poor people way they get
upset when you do so it can't be done if
you put it into you if you can put it
into your job description you know that
is actually a very practical way of
doing this that's right exactly putting
it in yes I which have a comment about
pre-service training probably a question
beyond changing the curriculum what what
do you actually do to make the the
teaching different in a way that would
actually improve the way you train and
contribute to what we are discussing
because this money I was talking to one
of the others funds about how they have
a program where the students spend 75
percent of the time in the field and
it's quite very different from what we
do where students have very short time
you are filled and most of you students
are probably coming from background that
is not health so the very first
experience they have dealing with the
health system is when they go out for a
short time and then they come back and
they have that degree and you go out so
what actually do you do if you have some
ideas on that beyond curriculum changing
gender's once in a while well you've
listed one is is that if you reverse
things a little bit rather than making
that practicum session kind of an
afterthought that will go through this
training you make it a central piece of
it that would be one way of reversing
things
but let me throw it out to peep 22
people any any ideas on on this because
we've got some but yeah Steven thank you
for me I think with pre-service training
or education we need to re-engineer the
process we know that what have been
doing the last 50 as hasn't worked there
must be reasons why this hasn't worked
and some studies have started to come
out that show the term the way we have
structured the whole thing with wrecked
our students is fraud because the way
the system works just ended it to
propagate or make people come into
medical education are those who have
access to certain amenities there are
many people who come from centers that
are banished and you get a preponderance
of those into the faster of university
education and they go through the system
and at the end of the day you want them
to go and work in a remote area we have
the best power power source that is is
probably solar energy there is an
erector Easter they are running on a
generator that works was mammoth and you
expect this kind of guy who has never
experienced very drive to work in the
village so I think we need you two to
two distinct this process the the type
of people get into the educational
system up in pre-service education that
is at the river of the doctors but also
I think we have also tended to give a
lot of emphasis or no training doctors
yet we know it is not cost-effective or
have not us we have not stopped and
thought about that because we know that
any rwanda for instance eighty percent
of the services we deliver that a
curative and preventive delivered in
Harris's centers which are run by NASA's
and other leaders avocadoes so why don't
we put emphasis there fast and may
instead of standing at a percent of
medical education budget on doctors I
put it in this middle avocadoes that is
another area we need to give emphasis
and thought the other point I wanted to
bring in different from this is uh where
is the role of the private sector and
all of this because we know the private
sector preserver a big role in the
distribution of Helena Waka's you know
they influence that a great deal because
if you look at distribution of erica's
mainly there in urbanized areas where
the private sector tends to offer them
inducements to stay but also in some
countries they have a successful
educational institutions especially when
you talk about the middle avocado and
when it's governments are struggling
with the production of human resources
for Harris they think they are producing
for for the public sector but at the end
of the day they're half share the
private sector so we need to get these
guys both at the National region and
grab refers to start really putting in
something there is a worker that is
going on with mines in the terms of
Harris and productivity they have
started turning around providing air of
this but we should always ask them
provide money to go into
producing people provide a headache
thank you proof bernas though his
question was he excluded the curriculum
I think it all all begins with the
curriculum also I've seen a country
where the training the strategy of
training changed from the normal like
the training in one institution go to
the preclinical and go to the clinicals
and actually put students from the
beginning in rural hospitals where they
had the teachers and they have hands-on
training from you do if for instance you
had me anatomy you come across anemia
you are linear an email you are doing
the anatomy physiology everything with
patient care everything together and
that was actually done with the revision
of the entire curriculum but what we
usually do is to conform with the global
structure which often does now work
within or is not meeting our needs a
wife but not meeting our needs and if we
could maybe we'll look at the way
between and repackage the training we
might be able to make more headway then
the way we do your training and conform
with the global knowledge take for
instance if you just repackage
Pediatrics care for example and tree the
bed level strictly on Pediatrics that
person becomes a specialist actually
because you are using the same books the
same is the content is the same the
skills will be the same in the end is
the same content but we've got we turn
to follow the norms and so in the end it
does not really meets yep yeah that's
right absolutely you know two points at
work that were meant what I directed I'd
like to respond to that question by also
bringing two two ideas one is the one
that that was brought up about the role
of the pie
sector in fact this experience in Mali
is is an example of private sector
involvement it was support to this
nursing school in gaol a very remote
area in Mali where with a little bit of
investment in a private school which
ended up really being a great model
because the quality of that that school
was so successful and I think they had a
ninety-five percent success rate in the
in depth in the exam afterward which
actually prompted people from Bamako to
start applying to go to that school way
up in the north and it's it points to
two things one is yes we need to invest
a lot more in there in the private
sector but also this idea that studies
are beginning to show that you have
better retention people like to go back
to where they're from they go back to
they like to go back and live and work
where they from there is up there is
some studies that are beginning to come
some results that show that you could do
a better with you could have a better
eat and a better retention strategy
might be to invest on decentralized
system and then recruitment and
placement from where people are from I
think Thailand has a lot of good success
with that by investing in really as a
strategy for rural health workers so I
think we need to we need to give some
thoughts about those just simple things
like why should we concentrate all the
schools in the capital city and so forth
because you've got two problems once
people have finished being trained you
know they if they don't find jobs in a
very competitive and rough urban
environment air chances of leaving the
health system altogether
becomes higher okay so and there is a
human and natural attachment that we
have to the region where we are from so
I think we need to be looking at that
you're doing that a little bit in Rwanda
as part of you engineering the whole
system what they are what you guys are
doing is actually revamping the whole
system because you inherited from the
old Belgian system you've got the a1 a2
and a3 nurses I think you've decided to
get rid of the a-threes and DA to to
invest in a cadre of a1 nurses and then
cut down the number of schools that
existed all to focus on quality so we'll
example of engineering of nursing
schools in Rwanda it's a it's not a joke
it's really they put a lot of emphasis
on that there were some tough decisions
to make because you really have the very
poor quality of education and as a
result you've had very very substandard
level of services where so they are you
know they are kind of regrouping and and
and and doing that and say let's invest
in this one cadre which is much closer
to the mid to have midwifery
introduction of midwifery is another
thing you did which you did not have
before so there are things you could do
if you put your hands to it and you say
okay this system i have is not working
how do I reform it and then embark in
that and yes the public sector is not
going to do it alone they cannot they
cannot the need and this is an area
where actually public sector work I'm
and private sector works people will pay
to go to school they will pay to go to
good school so rather than having these
two parallel systems which we used to
have how do we have complementarity so
that so that the investment is better I
see that we are actually going to okay
the last piece of this is increasing
work force effectiveness because because
as I said earlier we could
be spending a lot of time and energy on
the stuff we don't have control over
like people migrating and going and
rather than trying to stop them and
stuff why don't we stop and also focus
on the workforce that we currently have
and effectiveness of that workforce I
think we could actually close the gap a
little bit if we if we do this if we
invest on retention I know all of you
are interested in how to do this better
I i I'd you know there's so many things
that are being tried but this is the
nightmare we all have is you know those
workers that are there those few workers
that have remained in the country's what
do we do to retain them and you know
that there they are just lots of things
we could be doing in terms of motivation
and I think Ghana you've tried several
things right you've tried several things
related monetary motivation I don't know
if you want to share any of your
thoughts on that and that's where
players will have to come in and and and
indeed the workforce associations were
key in getting us where we are today but
important thing is that we saw that
there were things that people were
looking for most of us came out to do
our postgraduate training and I wouldn't
see the need to come back they the issue
of postgraduate training world was there
and we had to address by making sure
that we had a college that will give
people post early 20 we looked at the
incentive people people looked at those
of our seniors who who retired
as for people for instance you I a
doctor you you you get to retirement age
and you had matter or advice d the
social security that will be given to
you was yes penis and therefore people
began agitating for something better and
we had to look at how to do that and
doing it looking at the allowances
consolidating them into single salary
structure and making sure that their
retirement will be better for that
increased a lot of what goes into
people's pockets and there we saw a
difference there were other things you
are a doctor who and I this I call the
doctors who come out digital oh no we're
health workers orgasm yet and then what
digital some of us were analog people
with my mind and now we've got digital
people they come out all the good things
they might see very well young nurse or
not if it is a car must also drive a car
government made sure that that was done
not that it is given free DP but there
there is a package so that over time you
pay with some small interest and and
then people take it yeah add a small
team that blow buddies had three major
areas and we had to address yeah I
talked to one of your former ministers
one time and it was talking to me about
his impression after he had a big
meeting with the Ghanaian doctors good
name community in New York and it's
talking about just you know what are the
other things we could do to help which
is you know the people are just looking
for good schools for their children and
opportunities to buy a house and why we
need to be looking at those kinds of
things that's kind of at least extra
motivation but it better to focused a
little bit on this idea of productivity
too because we cannot just keep our eyes
closed on this in these issues that we
have a bunch of health workers there i
was in Sonic I'll recently talking to
the Ministry of Health and then they
said well if you could just help us
increase the
activities of our workforce here because
people just gotten into all this bad
habits you know we just government
workers we do the minimum and so forth
so anything we can do to really focus on
that I think that's as important as a
retention there's no sense of retaining
people who are not going to be
productive so you really need to work on
both parts of this you know I think we
have we have seen the kind of the four
areas where we think work is needed the
coalition building advocacy strategy
making sure we pay attention to policies
you've got some examples of areas where
policies could be enacted revisiting
what we do in pre-service in-service
training and education looking at ways
to support to ink to improve retention
and improve productivity of health
workers you see there we've included the
gender piece which is cross-cutting
which needs to be addressed it's it is a
major factor on distribution on
retention there is no sense closing our
eyes on the fact that a lot of our
female workers are working in areas
where safety is not always there and
harassment still exists and you know so
these these needs to be addressed
because because they do exist and and we
can pretend that the problem is not
there but the problem is this is an area
that is there is highly affected by
gender and gender dimension so our
strategy should have cross-cutting
interventions in gender so when we are
meeting to form these coalition's and
have advocacy it needs to have a strong
component and gender
when we are looking at reforming the
system we need to look at that gender
dimension as well ok so moving ahead the
agenda there you know in this country
there's a lot of excitement about the
Global Health Initiative the Obama
administration as made it very clear
that in fact last week between global
health council the first GHI plus the
list of thi plus countries were I'm sure
you you've talked about that during
these five days we know what those
countries are now so they're going to be
extra resources going to support this
there seems to be really commitment to
this country ownership it's one of the
things that people are really talking
about but as I said at the beginning of
my remarks that really need to be driven
at the [ __ ] by the country level you
know some people say well the way to do
it is just budget support so we know
that there's resistance from this
government to do that and that is a
problem some people take a very
practical approach to well let's see how
the aid is coming and do that but there
are opportunities in there the monies
are are there we supposed to do a lot
more with a little less but but but the
initiative the will the way this
government is organizing I think are all
opportunities so I think I think we have
interest we have and we we can seize
that at new momentum there's a common
platform for the for health systems that
the World Bank
the wh 0 and everybody is is is
mobilizing again is mobilizing for and
implementing this HR plans we are
finding out in our work that although
many of you have this plans depend i
really don't know exactly what to do
with them and how to take them further i
recommend a good step was if we don't
have costs associated with these and
that these really are going to be
meaningful exercises that financed need
to be integrally trick Utley involve in
these but moving these plans will be
extremely important it's not going to be
just enough to have them and say now we
have our HR plans because in himself
they're not gonna they're not going to
produce thing unless they are strongly
tied to what you're doing I think
Donna's will probably hold us
accountable and would want to see
results that's why I was saying at the
beginning that I don't think our window
of opportunity's is very going to be
wide open all the time I think unless we
start saying you know because of this
investment in human resources for health
this is how we improving the quality of
the work or this is you know we are
serving more people and so forth so is
going to be an issue let's see I think
these are yes I mean so the intention
here was was to give you some framework
for beginning to look at hrh in a
comprehensive way I think the problem we
all face is that this is a new area with
a lot of work it's not a new area it's
an area with a lot of opportunity but
the challenge that we have is this is
not a very professionalized field so
really the objective that we have is how
to make hrh how to professionalize it
many of you know that and
years ago maybe even five years ago we
had a small HR unit buried deep down in
some section of the ministry with very
limited functions to look at vacation
schedule for employees things like that
HR need to be much much more than that I
think you all said it for the beginning
you're beginning to say you know how can
we do this how can we have ownership I
think investing in this field to make it
more professional will be the first step
toward this and and I think there are
things that we can do you know how that
happened the linking the access maternal
health and the broader hrh strategy it
needs to be linked to to some certain
level of services otherwise people are
see going to see it as this nebulous
thing and then take action on GH common
platform and your national plans I mean
there are things you could do at your
own level I think I think because we
need so many people to get and we need
our brothers our sisters our nieces our
nephew to embrace the health field I
mean I think their stuff we can do at a
family level by encouraging our people
to go into this sector because we do we
do need the people okay so almost one at
a time but we could certainly have a few
reactions and comments yes sorry yeah
thank you very much for your talk it's
very interesting one I I like your
concluding comments about the
comprehensive approach because I was
getting a little concerned when the
comments the commentary on your
presentation by own group seemed to
suggest that we should focus on there
for want of a better phrase that way the
very basic needs it is very important I
think we need
to think through the process more
carefully because we whether we like it
or not we are now in a global world we
have an epidemiologic transition if you
look at our disease profiles these days
non communicable diseases are becoming a
very big burden the cancers are all over
the place and those are the things that
the people who study the cell biology
and the mitochondria deal with so we
need both spectrums I think for me that
is a key issue but in the environment of
scarcity against the question is how do
we manage our resources to be able to
deal with the bulk of the people who are
down there who need the basic care on
malaria and ERI and prevention of
maternal mortality and those basic
things as compared to the other spectrum
who are also important and need the cash
it's a big challenge but I think we
shouldn't run away from it and think
that everybody must be a village health
worker because that is where the big
problem is threat and just to support
that yourself planners and leaders there
is always a paradox in the the solutions
we choose you know if you choose to go
one way you have advantages in that
direction and then you have
disadvantages that are created because
of your focus and and the trick in
leadership is to balance and choose very
carefully and so you minimize the
disadvantages so just to support that I
think it's a very very wise isn't it
it's always it's always choice there are
always choices to make and so it's it's
it's so much about not just making the
right choice but mitigating the effect
because that is true it is it is like
one thing and the other yeah so ideas
are government thank you very much one
of the the challenges I see is really
particularly in training it's very
difficult to see results quickly so and
the partnerships are short-lived because
there is a need to see results or to
count count graduates or something like
that so because of that country's
struggle and this in this area because
they need really particularly with
universities colleges and so on they
need high-caliber graduates to do the
work and then also you have to measure
the results also the emphasis on the
research is very limited luckily in my
country the government has focused in
expanding investors which is really a
huge investment universities from three
or four now we're more than 20 or so so
the yield will be many years to come but
I think we need to focus I mean
government self to put their priorities
communities have to express their needs
and then that should guide really
whether the inverse service training and
so on and then this should be guided
also by a research and nobody wants to
to put money into research in developing
countries also so these are the areas i
think we need to work being
evidence-based also you know analyzing
our you know internal conditions because
the conditions are not the same also
similar so testing it you know improving
our curricula and sort this how we
develop the research units and other
areas thank you lovely Steve and I hope
you had a chance to share your again
your great model of Park which is that
partnership between communities and
health workers because where they they
create this partnership
or formal partnership there's
representations from the community and
the health service delivery site and the
whole focus is engaging on the quality
of services that this communities need
you know along with your with your
insurance scheme than and all of that
that there's really a good jump there
that I want to point you to which i
think is a beautiful model of of really
getting the needs making sure that the
community needs are addressed yes thank
modern museum yes it's interesting
listening to your presentation but when
we look at the issues of numbers then we
come to the issues of distribution one
of the key issues that come to mine is
the capacity is that we have in human
resource you need departments and
territories across our countries that
will manage what we have while we talk
about people living I think we should
try and concentrate on how we optimize
what we have and these are key issues
and in order to do that you need basic
information that will allow you to do
that and most of our countries lac léman
resource databases that are up to date
and that can be analyzed and give you
information on simple issues like
distribution how do you achieve this and
we also lack issues on staffing knows
who should be here specialty mix and all
these other things so I think these are
some of the areas what you're trying to
concentrate on and not put them to the
background thank you very much I totally
agree and now and for those i know i
don't think the IRS system is I think
it's being adaptive actually it's being
pilot cannabis pilot tested in in in
Ghana there is the health human
resources in
system which is an open source solution
that is now available downloadable free
and in fact there was a meeting of the
West Africa health office a couple of
weeks ago in Liberia I think there's an
it an and I think coyote from wahoo is
really really intent on I'm having this
if you've had some successes in eastern
and southern Africa installing iris the
government of Kenya is now installing it
there's there's discussion to adopt it
make sure it fits with everything you
guys are doing in in Rwanda so there are
some solutions that are beginning to be
available there are some open source
we're not open source evangelists but
but we think that it is one of the
solutions that's mostly affordable in
and you can have these solutions and and
adopt them to you need but but support
is available in this area and it's
widely recognized unless people have the
basic data and and five years ago I know
popular and everybody when you guys were
doing your work in in Liberia it was a
challenge to just start tallying you
know their the staff that exist because
the wide number of ghost workers that
that was still in the system and so
forth cleaning up the data and having up
that data is is a must and that's why if
you don't have it there's nothing you
can do so but there there are solutions
there are solutions that I can make a
plug for our own it each call iris human
resources information system and again
on our website it's downloadable you can
actually have a demo to see how it works
but but it's it's designed to actually
capture the data of all health workers
and their distribution so that and it's
been used as a basis for beginning to
form these coalition's